I don't have Dwayne Johnson here to
write tonight but um I do have someone
called The Rock
Adele meet the
room feels so good just to come here and
just uh give love to these incredible
artists and just watch and enjoy that's
Dwayne Johnson playing coin with
ee Awards
surprise
[Music]
and out of all the movie stars in the
world Johnson is Adele's number one
someone I've never met that I think I
would actually cry
who is The Rock but I know he goes by
Dwayne Johnson
the biggest wrestling family I'm excited
for this year the room is going to be
unlike any room we've ever seen this is
one of the strangest things I found out
the person that Adele has always wanted
to meet but never have is Dwayne Johnson
you've never met him right yeah and then
I found out that he's a huge fan of
yours too and now no no I don't I don't
have Dwayne Johnson here to write
tonight yeah the songstress had no idea
what host Trevor Noah and The Rock had
cooking that the wrestling Legend was
sneaking up behind her and boyfriend
Rich Paul but um I do have someone
called The Rock
Adele meet the rough the rough meet
Adele
first time ever
all right you two get acquainted we're
gonna keep the show moving
of course Adele was already having a
good night thanks to her eight
nominations including song of the year
and record of the year for easy on me
baby
[Music]
and while Adele's a Grammy vet Johnson's
new to music after spitting his first
bars on Tech Nine's 2021 single face off
it's about drive it's about power we
stay hungry we devour put in the work
but in the hours and take what's hours
can we get some more music from uh it
might be coming down the line well we're
looking forward to seeing drive and
power it's about drive it's about power
never mind
but even if Johnson continues putting
acting ahead of Music at least he got to
be a part of music's biggest night
[Music]